prime minister has traveled to Ukraine
for the first time John Craig is in
Westminster uh hello again John now
we've seen the footage of the two of
them shaking hands what more can you
tell us about that meeting I can tell
you that the Prime Minister has
announced new air defense for Ukraine on
his first visit he has confirmed that
the UK will bolster Ukraine's air
defense against what the number 10 calls
barbaric aerial assault and he is
expected to meet emergency responders on
that visit he has already as we've seen
from the pictures held talks with
President yelensky on Ukraine's military
advances say number 10 and
reconstruction plans
um he has said this is Mr sunac it is
deeply humbling to be in kieve and
pledged that the UK will continue to
stand by ukrainians in their fight he's
confirmed that that the UK will provide
a major new package of air defense to
protect Ukrainian civilians and critical
National infrastructure from an
internship barrage of Russian strikes
now number 10 says the 50 million pound
package of Defense Aid comprises 125
anti-aircraft guns and Technology to
counter deadly Iranian supplied drones
including dozens of Radars and
anti-drone electronic warfare capacity
and uh Mr sunac says I'm proud of how
the UK stood with Ukraine from the very
beginning I'm here today to say the UK
and our allies will continue to stand
with Ukraine as it fights to end this
barbaric war and deliver a just peace he
says
John thank you uh that uh footage there
of prime minister rishis your next first
visit to meet president zielinski in the
Ukrainian Capital cave and to announce a
new package of support